[Music]
these are trying times for Rugby Union
the Premiership the top League contest
in England has seen three of its 13
teams go under in the last year
Worcester Warriors wasps and London
Irish three clubs with more than 400
years of combined history all founded in
the 1800s and now dealing with the
aftermath of
administration the business model has
been under pressure for some time costs
have been rising fast partly due to
increased competition for players from
other leagues Revenue has not been
keeping up leaving clubs reliant on
Wealthy owners to keep their show on the
road when the pandemic hit the sports
rickety finances gave way so what can be
done many are pushing for change
including some of the private Equity
investors now involved at at all levels
of the game some want to see a global
calendar that would stop clubs and
countries battling over players and make
it easier for fans to know exactly when
they need to tune in the league game is
getting smaller too at least in England
fewer teams makes for fewer matches and
means that each Club gets a bigger slice
of whatever broadcast and sponsorship
money comes in the talent pool of
players is limited so if you don't need
so many of them the quality of the
product on the pitch should rise
some want the rugby itself to be faster
and more entertaining that means cutting
back some of the slower parts of the
game like video referee checks that
could attract new fans especially in
growth markets like the US and Japan but
hanging over all of this are some big
questions about the health risks
associated with playing professional
rugby the long-term future of the game
itself is far from
Clear